this is a virus that causes bird flu
there's a real pilot ality connected
with h5n1 virus and we haven't got a
vaccine for it yet that's a very
ubiquitous and we don't have a medicines
that really will treat it and over
almost fifty five percent of the people
that have come down with h5n1 flu have
died and this could be very very serious
to our world if in fact this virus
mutates enough to to be able to be
transmitted from human to human so far
it has not been able to be transmitted
very readily from you to me or from you
to your wife or girlfriend whatever the
case may be and that is saved us but it
continues to mutate and still lurking
out there and that's the biggest concern
that we have in the healthcare field
that somehow this h5n1 virus will mutate
so that's easily transmitted from human
human and we will have a huge problem on
our hands the second big one is the fact
that we have so many bacteria that is in
that drug that is really drug resistance
verses 1 and so on and so forth that and
we're getting staph infections in the
hospital and and TB that's very hard to
kill or cure from the old drugs we have
they're not as powerful enough those
those viruses mutated enough for
bacteria has changed enough so that the
things that we have are not capable of
killing them
for their spreading